das willkommen bei die rapper unter alte
mann heute auch wieder zwei leute da die
ich auch normalerweise jetzt nicht in
meiner playlist hätte aber wahnsinnig
populär und heiß diskutiert ich glaube
er hatte im letzten jahr das album mit
den meisten distrikte und jasko die lage
die lage ist stabil
wisst ihr darüber dir also bei mir nicht
so stabil bis zu müde die letzten tage
war ein bisschen anstrengend aber alles
q cells also er hat ein neues album und
das heißt auch noch mario versus jasko
gericht was ist der name programm
ihr dürft euch jetzt nur noch
gegenseitig und dass die anderen außen
vor oder was die anderen rapper sich
nicht trauen und zu dessen hamburger
übernehmen
wie gesagt dass es einen einblick in
unser privatleben wir sind auch privat
so machen sie ganz fertig und das leben
ist ja auch das ja alles spaß und da
haben wir gedacht geben wir den fans man
kleinen einblick wie wir wirklich sind
das wichtigste wird noch mal zeigen dass
wir uns auch über uns selber mal machen
können sondern auch einstecken können
als ich festgestellt habe beim vorhören
da ist ja auch einiges drin was
nachdenklich ist und zwar nicht nur um
hier auf euren kann man das sagen es
fahrräder mentor oder förderer kann man
so sagen also auf jeden fall ein vorbild
ok also der hat ja gerne auf seinem
album dann einen nachdenklichen fleck
den man dann eventuell im radio spielen
kann geht es immer um frauen glaube ich
und oder um schicksal das was da habt
ihr aber mehr zu bieten
und es gibt einen track da sind ja auch
oder rappt tatsächlich über rap business
und das leben seid ihr auch immer seid
ja auch im tatsächlichen leben so leute
die sich wirklich damit ständig
auseinandersetzen was ihr da macht und
was das bewirkt
ja klar so also im alltag machst du
manchmal sachen worüber du nicht
nachdenkt aber spätestens wenn du nachts
im bett liegt dann vergeht das ganze
nochmal längste bauer was sage ich da
passiert was da passiert also ich
persönlich bin ein sehr nachdenklicher
mensch nicht bei dir
er hat schon recht also man lässt ja
immer wie er gesagt hat im bett dann
revue passieren was ist da passiert und
das leben ist halt facettenreich man
kann nicht nur immer ernster man kann
nicht nur immer spaß haben und deswegen
als das auf jeden fall so dass man auch
was man macht ob das richtig ist
das ist auch wie im video also ist mein
erster ansprechpartner wenn ich wüsste
hauptbahnhof stehen dann oder andersrum
mit dem video jetzt das ist schon alles
richtig so wie das dargestellt das heißt
ihr seid auch die besten freunde im
wahren leben ja klar wir können uns
schon seit klein auf
seit fünfte klasse 5 damals haben wir
beschlossen wir rappen zusammen ja so
nicht so da erst widersprüche wissen sei
kein thema und wir haben zusammen
angefangen so zusammen durch und das
passt alles schon also abgesehen von der
musik sind wie richtige brüder wenn ich
jetzt da rein hören
da geht es unter anderem darum dass die
eltern nicht unbedingt stolz sind auf
das was er macht wenn ich die richtigen
rückschlüsse daraus ziehen würde ich
sagen das war ja letztes album meine
eltern hören würde dann dürft also würde
ich gar keine musik mehr mal du kannst
das vielleicht verstehen dass sie das
nicht gut finden und also das ist ja
nicht mehr in richtung wenn jetzt das
lied sei gewiss etwas worüber wir
gesprochen haben falls spiel wenn die
sagen okay das ist gut
damit sagt so gut zu machen aber wenn
schon die anderen lieder zeigen wird wo
wir ein bisschen auf die kacke hauen
wenn du bist dann kritisch gucken
es gibt tricks wo er wirklich das
ausleben auch mit farid bang entwicklern
nach allen regeln der kunst da wird sehr
stark ich sag mal explizit sexual
schriftverkehr in praktisches
geschrieben und körperteile in den
mittelpunkt der handlung genommen aber
in anderen tracks setzt euch damit
überall ich sag mal sehr differenziert
darüber auseinander wie ich die
beziehung zwischen mann frau freundin
freund wie passt das eine zum anderen
das leben ist ja also man ist ja
einerseits angesprochen dass man
einerseits nachdenkliches andererseits
lebt man auch komplett seine jugend aus
und nutzt die möglichkeiten die man
damit möglichkeiten die lieder entstehen
auch folgendermaßen also wenn ich
schlechte laune ab entsteht so ein song
wie falsches spiel
wenn ich getrunken habe und bisschen
spaß gehabt habe oder sonst was dann
schreibe ich darüber wisse also je nach
alltag was gerade passiert ist bevor ich
ins studio gehen
das heißt ihr lebt wirklich alle
facetten ihrer persönlichkeiten aus und
das eine schließt das andere nicht aus
irgendwo übertreibt noch ein bisschen
aber so im großen ganzen demo des
kanzlers studien
ich hab auch schon davon gehört wenn man
ein erfolgreiches rapper markt gebracht
wir stehen immer die professoren vorne
eine grüne und bauern ein und greifen
und die bilden darum dass man neue
möglichkeiten weiblich in weiblicher
hinsicht
ich will jetzt mit wohl gern aus
deswegen sagt sozusagen die
möglichkeiten die ich musik höre
neben bisschen gilt das bisschen geld
reinkommt und ich spaß daran habe immer
so ist dass man die frauen etwas nächste
abkriegt aber vielleicht ist da die
grenze die die frauen die man abkriegt
sind für den spaß und aber man sucht
eine freundin oder das ist ja eine große
großer punkt trick falsches spiel
ich sag ja noch mal weißt du was wird
schlimmer ist schnell in die die frau
fürs leben können und das frisst mich
innerlich obama
zwei junge wirklich wird
also in unseren kreisen ist dass du
lernst aber das ist diese nur teilweise
selber schuld sobald eine ernste frau zu
mir ankommt versuche ich das schlecht
ich glaube es liegt ja auch daran wenn
man so eine bestimmt wenn ein viele
leute kennen und ich sag mal wenn man
mädel kennenlernt das ist ja sehr
schnell raus was man macht und dann weiß
man ja nicht mehr ist es wirklich liebe
oder bist du mehr fan was ist das
realisierung
es gibt zwei probleme zwei verschiedene
arten von frauen zurück einmal die
fragen von frauen geben die deshalb nur
die mit der dann zusammen sind nur wegen
diesem film und so der sich schnell gibt
andererseits ist es wieder schwer eine
beziehung zu führen mit einer person die
vielleicht nicht wirklich liebt aber die
hat dann keine lust auf dieses ganze
rating was damit verbunden lassen
deswegen ganz anderen seite beschreiben
beschreiben wir im track nichts hält
ewig wie ich mich zum beispiel auf eine
beziehung einlassen und lust auf diese
beziehung habe aber die frau macht diese
beziehung kaputt indem sie misstrauisch
ist weil wegen dieser ganzen geschichte
sie verfolgt mich rein oder sonst wir
haben ein bisschen pech was du die wahre
liebe betrifft habt ihr das alles schon
erlebt also eigentlich schon ich hoffe
also wenn du wenn du mich gerade siehst
ich suche dich da sind vor allem die
fans die denken dass sie keine fans sind
sondern sich wirklich lieben obwohl sie
sich ja gar nicht kennen es gibt ein
beispiel wo wirklich ein musiker ein fan
geheiratet hat und ich soweit ich weiß
mit der immer noch dass zumindest sehr
lange zusammen war aber das war kein
rapper dass ich auch glaube ich 30 jahre
oder jünger
als keine ahnung sicher war von einem
deutschen rapper gehört das kann super
funktionieren in einzelfällen aber oft
ist es halt schwierig deswegen promis
sind ja meistens untereinander
verwandelt deswegen sind sagt justin
bieber und selena gomez zusammen weil
die wissen die eine oder der andere ist
nicht fern von mir sondern wenn dann ist
er mit wegen mir mit mir zusammen genug
geld haben sie beide aber im rap
business ist das angebot an
ich habe die richtige der repariert
haben überhaupt schwer oder rapperin
oder wie viel gibt es kritiker gibt aber
die kriegt immer einen auf die nase ich
weiß nicht ob die irgendwann mal einen
richtigen holz fertigen
ich hab gehört bevor die überhaupt russ
kam haben die division hamster so ins
laufrad gesteckt damit die abnimmt
bevor die überhaupt massen auch wieder
schön freundlich ihr von eurer du musst
sie das mikro geben also das habe ich
nur gehört über geldspritzen ja aber das
ist die sommer wenn ein mädel rap
würzigen ist respektlos und ich also ich
sag mal eine deutsche rapperin ja ihr
wisst schwester m was soll ich dazu
sagen
wir kennen den hintergrund von schwester
er wohnt wie soll ich wenn sie das muss
ich raus gekommen ist so könnt ihr euer
album hört es ist ein stark maskulines
business das rap business oder ja klar
deswegen musst du dich auch durch harte
ansagen durchkämpfen
weil wenn du wenn du respekt zeigt sehen
sie das als schwäche also ich meine
respektvoller mensch aber
in dieser szene kanzlers schwer zeigen
weil das die nutzlast also sie sehen das
als schwäche und denken die kündigung
greift wie kriegt ihr denn an den spagat
hin wenn er eben doch sehr nachdenklich
wir wissen aber wir wissen also ich
sagte original was mein vater sagt mein
vater sagt folgendes du bist 24 wieso
machst du dass das duo kinderkacke da
sagt mein vater dann sag ich guck mal
papa ich mach das schon länger ich habe
spaß daran dass eine sache die mir in
diesem harten leben ein bisschen spaß
bereits interesse und sobald das thema
zoos anfängt und blogs ab
kein streit zu aber auf der anderen
seite venstre wenn wir zu hause besuchen
oder sonne und ich nicht da bin dass er
falsch immer im nachhinein dann geben
die so anja mein sohn macht musik das
schreibt seine texte selber der geht ins
studio gedrehte videos der gibt konzert
und sowas müsste aber sobald ich da bin
namen machen dich runter vor aber ich
verstehe das ja ich verstehe das
vollkommen nur gesagt sobald es die man
fängt an blogs mit der realität zu tun
ihr sagt etwas was ich es geht um
[ __ ] und was haben wir noch für ein
anderes wort für das männliche primäre
geschlechtsorgan ich weiß es nicht
wohin ballermann ländern
das wollte ich sagen ohne zu lügen
aber in der realität ist es doch
meistens nicht so oder gibt es rapper
die das auch leben weil ich meine welche
frauen lassen sich so behandeln dass
genau die gleiche denkweise hat sich
auch bevor ich fahre dann kennengelernt
haben und das tourleben begonnen hat und
dann habe ich mich schon gefragt aus
welchen löchern dir ausgebrochen aber es
gibt vielleicht auch nur die gibt es
wirklich
also ich sagte ehrlich christoph wir
waren damit verrät oft die ersten drei
konzerte spaß gesagt sag ich hoffe mit
der nicht warnt matsch und ich sehr
zurückhaltend und schüchtern
also wir haben es gar nicht getraut weil
er unseren augen nicht getraut was da
abgeht weißt du ja und dann kann man
langsam ran
im wahrsten sinne des wortes ich bin ich
bin ich bin froh dass du sagst langsam
aber für die ist ja fürs leben wünsche
euch dass nicht das leben ist dann eine
ernsthafte glückliche familie in einer
schönen idyllischen stadt wie jeder der
silo hat das auch der sitzt jetzt auch
lieber zu hause und mädchen rasen als
wasser red oder interviews gibt was war
jetzt seine rasend komisch 20 also 1920
dachte ich okay wenn die wände 24 bis 24
26 kann zu heiraten ist ein gutes alter
finde ich war ja nicht zu früh zu spät
ist wenn ich 24
langsam kritisch so echauffierte vor 30
also ich hab's geschafft
zum glück aber ich wünsche euch aber es
macht ihr dann seid ihr dann auch rapper
wenn ihr heiratet oder muss man nach
wacken macht dann macht ihr eigentlich
und was noch nebenher ist eine
berufsausbildung studium oder
irgendwas eine ersten moment gar nicht
gar nicht oder wird man dann produzent
irgendwann oder über so was die wege
stehen ja offen muss ja nur noch durch
die tür gehen also wenn das irgendwann
mal ich will nicht mehr mit
aber ich habe überlegt ob ich das nicht
mehr anfangen würde also insbesondere
kombiniert mit einem flow wäre der
hammer die leute sterben
ich weiß nicht welches musikgenre das
wäre das wäre auf jeden fall mehr
richtung geht mehr richtung
was hast du denn so eigentlich gott ich
höre gerne elektronische musik aber das
vergisst man nicht das thema dann denken
alle dass immer wieder bei die rapper
unter altem hat ja also ich danke euch
niemals ich wünsche euch viel erfolg mit
dem album also sind tolle titel drauf
also die man auch hören kann wenn man
nicht auf explizite bord warg steht also
also findest du da das sind jetzt titel
drauf die auch unsere eltern hören
können absolut ein absolut doch doch und
das ist genau das ist der grund wieso
titel ist gemacht ich bin schon mal
stolz auf euch dann spielen dank so